lot of people want to be famous but i
never wanted to be famous
[Music]
all right kobe mahat thank you so much
for joining me on 20 minute leaders
i'm really happy to be here okay this is
so great you know i actually grew up
watching you on tv i grew up in tel aviv
and watching the children's channel and
and all the different shows that you got
to be a part of and
and we actually even i have actually got
to study
under your command in a a program where
you taught us how to act in front of a
camera
so it's nice to close the slip after all
these years i i actually
taught you i think uh how to host not to
act
and there's a big difference as you can
remember uh
from um acting and hosting it's
completely different
profession so it sounds like i already
failed my first test
after all these years no scores here
no scores here that's that's amazing so
kobe you know
a tank commander in the army going on to
study psychology and organizational
behavior
in your masters and all of a sudden you
find yourself as one of the biggest
stars in israel
on the children's show practically an
idol for every kid growing up in israel
i have to understand how this whole
sequence came about
well it was virtually a mistake
i wasn't meant to be i was going to be
um
my route since since i was i think 15
was
uh i wanted to i wanted to be a
psychologist ever since my mother took
me to the
to a book fair and bought me uh
the origins of dreams of uh sigmund
freud
i i don't know if that's the name of the
book anyways
those two books sort of
paved the way for me to be a
psychologist that's what i thought i
wanted to be that's what i
started uh studying uh after i i was
done with the army
uh i think um three months after i i was
done with the army i already joined the
tel aviv university and started uh
studying
and what happened is between the first
and the
second degree a friend of mine
just thought that we had the same
sense of humor that was very nice of him
to think we had a sense of humor to
begin with
anyways uh we wrote something very naive
and he sent it to all kinds of
broadcasters
and one of them a very famous one in
israel a major
broadcaster in israel keshet decided
that it was
pretty good and that they were not going
to
produce it but they are looking for
new writers for a tv show when we became
writers
uh right off in writing tv
and ever since i just started
writing until today i'm writing for a
lot of
adults and kids uh shows and i went to
the
children's channel just to write and
they told me that i should host
i didn't know i was able to host
wow okay so you you're writing i was
willing to jump to the
to the really deep end of the water
so and and how quick was this transition
so you go there to write and all of a
sudden you find yourself a host
how quickly does it go from zero to 60
and it was
an icon it was pretty quick
it was 2000 and on in 2000 there was
only one children's channel in israel so
if you were
one of the hosts you were a mega hit
between the kids and their parents
immediately and until
2000 it was pretty quick uh becoming a
huge
success from zero to uh 100 in
no time insane so kobe i you know trying
to summarize this whole experience for
me
you know you go on daily on this
children's channel and and
you are an icon and you're a role model
how old are you at that point when you
when i was 27 i was pretty old for a tv
uh a children's tv presenter i was 27 i
always always had a sort of a baby face
so
nobody really knew but i was pretty old
is but that's a lot of responsibility
like you're you're
you're taking on this innate
responsibility you're not just a host
you're a role model
for kids growing up in everything you do
when you walk down the street and the
things you say on tv
on and off camera do you do you feel
that responsibility or is it like
you know what i think everybody was uh
over exaggerating the
role modern thing i i think that the
guideline
the guidelines i had and i always told
other hosts that came after me was just
pure common sense
if i was standing in the street and i
wanted to cross the road
i would go and wait for the green light
maybe as an adult sometimes i i could i
could
you know you could cut some corners and
and crossed on the red light but
i i took it upon myself to understand
that some
some uh kids and their parents may be
standing and watching me
and but that's what that was about it
you shouldn't exaggerate i was over 20
uh
27 i could uh drink
alcohol in parties it's okay i wasn't
alarmed if a paparazzi
caught me drinking it's okay i'm i'm old
enough
so everything within limits just pure
common sense
and and talk to me about this about
writing so you you transition
from from being a host there you're
you're writing for these for a lot of
different shows you appear in a lot of
these shows as an actor yourself what is
it about this writing that really caught
your attention because
again you were you were going to be a
psychologist you were going for
organizational behavior how do you where
does this writing
aspect come from well i think it's a bug
it's a bug in the system and it's a bug
that uh it's some sort of a tick that
when it hits you and if if it's right
for you
it's really hard it's it's a pandemic
you know a lot of people want to be
famous but
i i never wanted to be famous still my
my um main attraction to this
area of to this career is not being
famous
so what i really liked is the the inter
the um you didn't
have to have any intermediate between
you and the audience it was very
um you know
forward could you could have touched
them it was very very immediate
um and i i never knew i wanted to do it
sometimes you're very talented it's in
something you have not
tried yet maybe you're a great cook or a
great
knitter i don't know if you tried
knitting have you tried it in my life
maybe you're very talented and there is
some
sometimes someday someone who is a great
knitter
will find uh will find this um you know
talent in you
and you'll become a knitter oh yeah i
should change my name it's not it's not
my name here
okay it's crazy
and the zoomie was nissim or something
wait somebody but toby
you know i i wanna i wanna go to this
moment where you're writing a show
and you or you're writing a movie and
you work on it for years and you cast
and you get funding and i never work on
anything for years
never really yes uh in the last six
years
i've i've written and directed six
movies
six movies in six years
and i think that's an israeli record and
i'm i'm all for immediate satisfactions
i'm not
i'm envious of people that can wait and
and dream
and and you know uh sit
sit under the their ideas for some so
long
i'm very very fast um
i'm when i'm getting into a new
production i'm
going in there like a bulldozer
sometimes you have to
attract sponsors yeah best in the movie
i'm i'm not shy of of begging people
of uh um making presentation of anything
but i think that my record um speaks for
itself that's
that's that's unbelievable six movies
and just avatar i think took 30 years to
produce
but it's a great movie and i'm i'm not
i'm not even in it's not the same level
i'm not i don't know of course
but you know israel is a very small
country
and we have only i don't know about nine
million people that's
the the population it's very small so
the budgets for the movies are
really small but as an israeli and
everybody who
has done anything in israel in israel
whether
it's gonna whether it's being uh a tank
commander in the israeli army
or making a movie you know that we know
how to
make a dollar and a half out of a dollar
definitely
definitely and you know i always say
also especially here
in my community in silicon valley in
stanford when they ask me what is it
about like israelis that like the number
one thing
i mainly say we get done um that's
what it's about at the end
that's true it is true but kobe egg so
still you work on a movie for a year
and it hits the theaters it's the
premiere you're sitting down with your
friends your family the
sponsors and the audience and this movie
starts
is there a fear in you of how people
will react to it
how are people going to react to your
masterpiece there's
excitement and uh
the excitement the excitement stems
also from a little bit from fear yeah
because
you know in some sense i i considered
myself i consider myself an
artist and the artist when you put your
art
uh to to the audience you know it's it's
it's very different sometimes the way
they
think you know sometimes when i uh plan
a joke
a lot of my movies are funny and when i
plan a joke
and i i think i know where the audience
is going to laugh and they're not
laughing it's
it's it you know it's like a punch in
the
stomach on the other hand sometimes they
laugh
when you they weren't meant to laugh
is it okay yes it's okay
i i was not uh embarrassed yet
hopefully it's not gonna happen amazing
amazing
but kobe that i mean that fear though is
that so
i mean i know a lot of people i'm i'm a
coder i'm a software engineer by
profession and an investor and when i go
and i look at deals or i look at code
that i write
and i pass it on to others i don't
really care if they criticize it if they
say it's awful if after we do it
it's it's objective it's science it's
math but when you put an art into
something you put your heart there i'm
sure it's really hard to make that
distinction
and maybe you haven't gotten burned but
is this something a phenomenon in the
industry that people
are fearful of or is this or or do you
example
is common i'm fearful first of all you
know
the couple there are a couple of
audiences that watches your
film the first one is
the actual audience that buy tickets and
goes to the theater
and they're my main focus
i want as many as they as i can
to come to the theaters and enjoy the
movie that's my main focus
the other kind of audience is the
critics right i really want the critics
to like my movie
but their opinion is only their opinion
so
although it has some distribution maybe
bigger than
n equals one it's you know it hurts when
someone
writes something bad on your movie it
happened to me
uh the third audience is my sponsors and
and my
investors i really want them to think
it's a good movie
so i'm mainly focuses on the
the big audience the real people and my
investors
the others i can live without their
love how do you work i want to know your
station do you have a computer and when
you write
a script or a movie do you just sit down
and start writing on a word document
do you write it by hand on a on a big
wall how does it work well
these days i'm actually thinking about a
new
idea i i was just i'm just done with the
the
filming of my new movie and it's now in
the process of editing
so i'm i'm actually thinking about a new
idea i don't know if it's going to be a
movie or a series or
whatever but i'm um i'm like
it's a stew inside my head i'm thinking
about it a lot
and for the last four days i think i'm
i have a story in my head and i'm
i'm thinking about tomorrow start start
just
sitting in front of my pc a stationary
computer not a laptop not an ipad
not in a restaurant or a coffee shop in
my house in my small room the one i'm
sitting here
in right now and i'm i'm just start
i start writing drafts is it just like
word comment do you just write as much
as you can and then
you know sleep on it and revise or do
you really think that through
oh i think i i think it's true and and
nevertheless some some of it is vomit
some of it is going to be erased in a
day
and the new thing is going to come up
it's going to it's a process of
i don't know two weeks to write just the
synopsis
uh the three three uh good pages of
the story with all the outlines and uh
and the main characters and everything
do you miss
going back in front of the camera and
being the star
i'm still in front of the camera camera
actually until the
covet 9 pandemic i was i had a
daily show six days a week with yellow
bozo
and it was called the daily report yeah
six days a week so i'm i'm pretty much
every day
on tv and it's a major broadcaster and
it's ratchet
and i've just since the kobe 19 uh
pandemic happened we were laid off but
i was just given the very pleasant
uh news today that uh we're coming back
next week so
i'm i'm still on tv it's a relief you
but it's very different to this kind of
tv than what you write because you're
it's two different worlds one you're a
host
the the rapport with the elbows are it's
a great show and but you're not acting
you're hosting
and then you you're a fiction writer for
movies and series
where it's completely you know made up
in in stores that you're creating right
yeah but it's not it's no different than
you being a great cook
and being a computer engineer right i
mean
we all have you know the some of the
things i
don't like on the screen on the little
screen or the big screen
is that it tries people are always
trying to
to um
make a two-dimension picture of you i'm
i'm
i'm a three-dimension p person and i
have a lot of interests
so i can write and i can host and i can
do a couple i actually can cook
so and i'm a really good father i think
so
i have a lot of interest and then one of
them
gives me the relief from the other i
mean if i only did writing or directing
i would go
crazy also if i was only a host
my my i would probably uh
be in a sanctuary like right now
this passion that you have of trying
interdisciplinary things and going
out to your passions is shines through
the screen but
i want one piece of advice that you
would give to any young
person not necessarily an entrepreneur
coder actor musician whatever
any person who who wants to go after
their dream is a little bit hesitant
and and from what i learned and i didn't
know all this about you is about how
passionate you are about going through
things that you
enjoy and you really love without being
scared of what others will say
or whether it fits this narrow box that
people are trying to put you in
yeah i think my main my main
advice i've i give advice to a lot of
young people
a lot of people approach me and ask for
my advice
who wants to send me scripts they have
written
from the ages of 14 until the uh the
i don't know that the oldest i i
got a street from was i think 65
wow and i i never i never turned down
nobody i read i read and i give them
advice
no no no always i i can always help and
i can't always take the idea and prove
but i give them advice and
maybe some some pinpoints to
how to uh make it better sometimes it's
not good enough and and i i tell the
truth softly
but i'm telling the truth always my main
advice for those people
is to be to stay very very
um curious when you're
curious as i am you explore and when you
explore
you discover a lot of things the way
i've become a director
was through being through me being a
host and a writer
i was watching the people that i worked
with
i i wanted to know what kind of camera
they used
why are they using this kind of dolly
and not the other one
how can you make this effect and not the
other and so
so on and i taught myself a little bit
of editing
and a little bit of uh content editing
and a lot of things
that are not necessarily uh
exactly directing but i've broadened my
horizons
and when i've done that i think i've
become a better
host and a better director so being
curious is very very
important i love it okay so kobe three
words that describe you
one of them is curious i'm gonna use
that already i i just wanted to say
curious curious and curious because
i think you know what a lot of people
think um
being smart you know okay i'll give you
another one that i'm very good at
i'm i'm very organized okay and
one of the psychologists i worked with i
had a
very interesting show on television with
professor amos he told me that
uh he he said he always says that the
the person who succeed in life
is the the one who is organized over the
one who is
smart and i mean it's very good to be
both but if you have to choose one
being organized is very very important
and
i'm i'm very if you could see my my my
table here it's very organized
and i'm i think because i do
all sorts of things and there's a lot of
scrambled eggs inside my head
i need some some organization to the
system
and being organized is a very important
thing being curious is very
important and i think uh the third
which i'm not sure i'm always
good at but it's very important to stay
humble
and i say that because
of course as a person on tv i also
made this scene of hebrews
everybody does that on television we
then tend
to think that um the sun shines
from our butts it it's never true
and times like this like covet 19
and what it happened what it made to our
indus
industry made a lot of people very very
humble
and being humble in the first place is
gives you a soft cushion to land on
i love it kobe i can't believe 20
minutes are up and this was so inspiring
to dakaba for for all the information
for uh giving me so much enjoyment
growing up uh really much this is uh
actually uh footage from my new film
it's called full full speed
when is it is it going to be in theaters
on like how do we even
watch it after of course it's going to
be well the
premiere is supposed to be in august
1st of august hopefully if every things
it's going to be okay with the
with the kovit 19 thing uh actually
we're depending
on uh the hollywood um uh industry
to release their their films that that
will
uh ignite the israeli film
um industry so um
i'm gonna be ready and it's a great
movie about
women um strength
it's really good i can't wait kobe
was written by a man thank you very much
michael
bye bye bye
you